[Music]
In the next 10 to 15 minutes, here's uh
I guess my promise to you. I'm going to
give you some information
that will be high level. There will be
some practical component to it. But this
information I'll give you within the
next 6 months will be very relevant and
it will put you in the best position to
build the best AI applications to build
the best agents that are believable,
capable, and reliable.
I know we we going to get there.
You know what? Just for you. There we
go. You're welcome. So, we're going to
be talking about a memory. Um,
we're going to be talking
about the stateless applications that
we're bu building today and how we can
make them stateful. We're going to be
talking about the prompt engineering
that we're doing today and how we can
reduce that by focusing on persistence.
We're going to be turning the responses
in our AI application and making our
agents build relationship with our
customers and all of it is going to be
centered around memory.
So I'm going to do a very quick
evolution of what we've been seeing for
the past two to three years.
We started off with chat bots. LMN power
chatbots. They were great. Chat GPT came
out November 2022 and yeah exploded.
Then we went into rag. We gave this chat
bots more domain specific relevant
knowledge and it gave us more
personalized responses. Then we begin to
scale the compute, the data we're giving
to the LLMs and they gave us emerging
capabilities, right? Reasoning uh tool
use. Now we're in the world of AI agents
and agentic systems
and the big debate is what is an agent,
right? What is an AI agent? I don't like
to go into that debate because that's
like asking what is consciousness
um is a spectrum. the agenticity and
that's a word now agenticity
of uh of an agent is is a spectrum so
they're different levels
I came here and I saw Whimo and to me
was pure sorcery we don't have that in
the UK and they're different levels of
um self-driving so you can look at the
genetic spectrum in that respect we have
a minimal agent whereas an LLM running
the loop great then you have a level
four is autonomous agent a bunch of
agents that have access to tools you
they can do whatever they want. They're
not prompted in any way or a minimal
way. But this is how I see things is a
spectrum. So what is an AI agent? It's a
computational entity with awareness of
his environment through perception,
cognitive abilities through an LLM and
also can take action through tool use.
But the most important bit is there is
some form of memory short-term or
long-term.
Memory is important. It's important
because we're trying to make our agents
reflective, interactive, proactive, and
reactive and autonomous. And every most
of this, if not all, can be solved with
memory.
Um, I work at MongoDB and we're going to
make we're going to connect the dots,
don't worry. So, this is all nice and
good. This is what what you look at if
you um double click into one AI agent
is. But the most important bit to me is
I'll go slide. People are taking
pictures. Sorry.
All right, let's go. The most important
bit is memory. And when we talk about
memory, the easy way you can think about
it is short-term, long-term, but there
al other distinct forms, right? Um,
conversational entity memory, knowledge,
data, store, cache, working memory.
We're going to be talking about all of
that today. So, these are the high level
concepts.
But let me go a little bit metal.
why we're all here um today in this
conference is because of AI, right?
We're all architects of intelligence.
The whole point of AI is to build some
form of computational entity that
surpasses human intelligence or mimics
it. Then AGI,
we're focused on making that
intelligence surpass humans in all tasks
we can think of. And if you think about
the most intelligent humans, you know,
what determines the intelligence is
their ability to recall. It's their
memory. So if we if AI or AGI is meant
to mimic human intelligence is a
no-brainer, no pun intended, that we
need memory within the agents that we're
building today. Does anyone disagree?
Good. I would have kicked you out. Um,
okay, let's go. So humans, you in your
brain right now, you have these, you
have this. This is not what it looks
like, but it's close enough. You have
different forms of memory, and that's
what makes you intelligent. That's what
makes you retain some of the information
I'm going to be giving you today. There
is short-term, long-term, working
memory, semantic, episodic, procedural
memory. Um, in your brain right now,
there is something called a cerebellum.
I always get the word wrong, but that's
where you store most of the routines and
skills you can do. Can anyone here do a
backflip?
Really? Wow. You just see my excitement.
Um
your the information or the knowledge of
that bat flip is actually stored in that
part of your brain. So I heard it's 90%
confidence by the way
that is actually it is right. I'm not
going to do one but but it's stored in
that part of your brain. Now you can
actually mimic this in agents and I'm
going to show you how. But now we're
talking about agent memory.
Agent memory is the mechanisms that we
are implementing to actually make sure
that states persist in our AI
application.
Our agents are able to accumulate
information, turn data into memory and
have it inform the next ex execution
step. But the goal is to make them more
reliable, believable, and capable.
Those are the key things.
And the core topic that we are going to
be working on as AI memory engineers is
on memory management. We're going to be
building memory management systems. And
memory management is a systematic
process of organizing all the
information that you're putting into the
context window. Yes, we have like large
context window, but that's not for you
to stuff all your data in. That's for
you to pull in the relevant memory and
structure them in a way that is
effective that allows for the response
um to be relevant.
So these are the core components of
memory management. Generation, storage,
retrieval, integration, updating,
deletion. There's a lie here because you
you don't delete memories. Humans don't
delete their memories except traumatic
one and you want to forget. But we
really should be looking at implementing
forgetting mechanisms within the memory
management systems that we're building.
You don't want to delete memories. And a
different research papers are looking at
how to implement some form of forgetting
within agents.
But the most important bit is retrieval.
And I'm getting to the MongoDB part.
This moving around um this is rag. It's
very simple, right? because we've been
doing it as AI engineers. Um, MongoDB
is that one database that is core to rag
pipelines because it gives you all the
retrieval mechanisms. Rag is not just
vector. Vector search is not all you
need. You need other type of search and
we have that with MongoDB. Anything you
can think of, you're going to be hearing
a lot about MongoDB in this um in this
conference today. But this is what rag
is and you level up. You go into the
world of agentic rag, right? You give
the retrieval capability to the agent as
a tool. And now we can choose when to
call on information.
There's a lot going on. I I'll send this
somehow to you guys or you can come to
me and I'll um LinkedIn it to you. Add
me on LinkedIn
and just ask for the slice and I'll send
it to you. Richmond on LinkedIn. Um this
is memory.
MongoDB
is the memory provider for Aentic
systems. And when you understand that we
provide the developer, the AI memory
engineer, the AI engineer all the
features that they need to turn data
into memory to make the agents
believable, capable, and reliable. You
begin to understand the importance of
having a technology partner like MongoDB
on your AI stack.
So these are this is the same um image
but just a bit more focused and not a
different memory. So I'm going to skip
through this slide because I go into a
bit of detail. Um I'm also going to give
you a library. I'm working on an open
source library. I'm ashamed of the name.
I was trying to be cool when I came up
with it. It's called Memoriz.
Um
you can type that on Google. You'll find
it. But it has all the design patterns
of all of this memory that I'm showing
you. for this memory types and that I
will show you as well. But there are
different forms of memory and AI agents
and how we make them work. So let's
start with persona who's is anyone here
from open AI
leave. I'm joking. Um well a couple a
couple months ago right so they they
gave chat GBT a bit of personality right
um and they didn't do a good job but
they are going in the right direction
which is we are trying to make our
systems more believable right we're
trying to make them more human we're
trying to make them create relationship
with the consumer with the users of our
systems persona memory helps with that
and you can model that in MongoD DB,
right? This is memories. You if you spin
up the library, it helps you um spin up
all of this um different type of memory
types. So, this is persona. Um I have a
little demo if we have time. Um
but this is persona memory. This is what
it will look like in MongoDB. Then
there's toolbox.
Um the guidance from OpenAI is you
should only put uh the schema of maybe
10 to 21 tools in the context window.
But when you use your database as a
toolbox where you're storing the JSON
schema of your tools in MongoDB, you can
scale because just before you hit the
LLM, you can just get the relevant tool
using any form of search. So that's
toolbox that's me that's a toolbox
memory and that's what it would look
like right you would store all this is
how you model it in uh MongoDB you store
all the information of your JSON schema
now you'll begin to understand that
MongoDB gives you that flexible data
model the document data model is very
flexible it can adapt to wherever data
wherever model you want your data to
take wherever structure and you have all
of the retrieval capabilities graph
vector text geospatial query
in one database.
Conversation memory is a bit obvious,
right? Back and forth conversation with
uh chat GPT with Claude. You can store
that in your database as well in MongoDB
as conversational memory. And this is
what that would look like. Time stamp,
time stamp, and you have a conversation
ID and you can see something there
called recall recency and associate
conversation ID. And that's my attempt
at implementing some memory signals. Um
but and that's goes into the forgetting
mechanism that I'm trying to implement
in my very famous library memories. Um
I'm going to go through the next slides
a bit quicker because I want to get to
the end of this.
Workflow memory is very important. You
build your agentic system, they execute
a certain step. Step one, step two, step
three, it fails. But one thing you could
do is the failure is experience. It's
learning experience. You can store that
in your database. I see you nodding.
You're like, "Yeah." um you can store
that in your database and you can then
pull that in in the next execution to
inform the LLM to not take this step or
explore other paths. You can store that
in MongoDB as well. You can model that
because what you have with MongoDB is
that memory provider for your agentic
system and that's what this is what that
looks like when you model it. An example
of it anyway. So we have episodic
memory, we have long-term memory, we
have an agent registry, you can store
the information of your agent as well.
Um, and this is how I do it. Uh, you can
see the agent has tools, persona, all
the good stuff. There's entity memory as
well. So, there's different forms of
memory. And the memory the memoriz
library is very experimental and
educational, but it it encapsulates some
of the memory and implementation and
design patterns that I'm thinking of on
an everyday basis that we're thinking of
in MongoDB. So, MongoDB, you probably
get the point now, the memory provider
for Agent Tech systems. There are tools
out there that focus on memory
management. Um, MEGPT, ME Zero, Zep,
they're great tools, but after speaking
to some of you folks and some of our
partners and customers here, there is
not there is there is not one way to
solve memory. and you need a memory
provider to build your custom solution
to make sure the memory management
systems that you're able to implement
are effective. So we really understand
the importance of managing data and
managing memory and that's why earlier
this year we acquired Voyage AI. Now
they create the best
no offense open AI embedding models in
the market today. Voyage AI embedded
models are we have a text multimodel we
have re-rankers and this allows you to
really solve the problem or at least
reduce AI hall elucination within your
rag and aentic systems and what we're
doing and what we're focused on the
mission for MongoDB is to make the
developer more productive by taking away
the considerations and all the concerns
around managing different data and all
the process of chunking in retrieval
strategies. We we pull that into the
database. We are redefining the
database. And that's why in a few months
we're going to be pulling in Voyage AI,
the embedded models and the rerankers
into MongoDB Atlas and you will not have
to be writing chunking strategies for
your um for your data. I see a lot of
people nodding. Yeah, that's good. So,
MongoDB is a is a household name to be
honest. with um I watched MongoDB IPO
back when back when I was in university.
I bought the stocks when I was in
university um free just free. I already
had about £100. Um I was broke but
we are very focused and we take it very
seriously making sure that you guys can
build the best AI products, AI features
very quickly in a secure way. So MongoDB
is built for the change that we are
going to experience now, tomorrow, in
the next couple years. I want to end
with this. You know who these two guys
are?
Damn. Okay, this is Hob and Wiso. They
won a Nobel Prize um in the late 90s,
but they did some research on the visual
cortex of cats. um they experimented
with cats that this probably wouldn't
fly now, but back in the 50s and 60s
things were a bit more relaxed. But they
found out that the visual cortex of the
brains between cats and humans actually
worked by learning different hierarchies
of representation. So edges, contours
and abstract shapes. Now people that are
in deep learning would know that this is
how convol convolutional neural network
works. And the research that these guy
these guys did inspired and informed
convolutional neural networks. That's
face detection, object detection. It's
it all comes from neuroscience. So we
are architects of intelligence. But
there is a better architect of
intelligence. It's nature. Nature's
created our brains. It's the most
effective form of intelligence and well
some humans that I meet. But it's the
most effective form of intelligence that
we have today. and we could look inwards
to build this agentic system. So last
week Saturday myself and Tenu is the
chief AI scientist at MongoDB also the
founder of Voyage AI. We sat with this
three guys in the middle are
neuroscientists. Kenneth has been
exploring human brain and memory for
over 20 years and and over here is
Charles Parker. He's the creator of
MEGPT your letter and we are having
these conversation and once again we're
mirroring how we're bringing
neuroscientists and application
developers together to solve and push us
on the path of AGI. So that's my talk
done. Check out memories and you can
come talk to me about memory. Add me on
LinkedIn if you want this presentation.
Thank you for your time.
[Music]